[Música]
tras ser acusado por retener documentos
clasificados el expresidente de Estados
Unidos Donald Trump vuelve a enarbolar
la teoría de la conspiración contra él
asegura que en 2024 devolverá el país a
sus seguidores y que designará a un
fiscal especial para perseguir a Joe
biden
78 personas mueren en un naufragio en el
Mediterráneo frente a la costa de Grecia
mientras intentaban llegar a Europa la
noticia llega al tiempo que la ONU
informa que el mundo alcanzó un nuevo
récord de 110 millones de refugiados y
desplazados en 2022
para este jueves se espera que el ciclón
biparjoy clasificado como muy Severo
golpee India y Pakistán donde se llevan
a cabo las evacuaciones de unas 70.000
personas de algunos estados se esperan
mareas altas en el mar arábigo e
inundaciones en varios estados de estos
países
bienvenidos las noticias de France 24 en
español Soy Rosa Pérez mazeu y es para
mí un gusto acompañarlos abrimos esta
edición informativa en Estados Unidos
donde el expresidente Donald Trump quien
Hoy cumple 77 años calificó de
persecución política su audiencia penal
por ocultar documentos clasificados de
la Casa Blanca tras declararse inocente
Este martes en Miami el expresidente y
ahora precandidato celebró uno de sussa
primeros actos de campaña en New Jersey
Alba Santana nos amplía
corrupto y mentiroso fueron los
adjetivos causó Donald Trump para
referirse a la administración de Joe
biden en un acto de campaña desde su
club de golf en bethminster Nueva Jersey
el republicano volvió a asegurar que
todas las imputaciones en su contra son
falsas yo soy el que sigue la ley Yo soy
el único
es Joe biden y su corrupto departamento
de Justicia ellos son los que creen que
está por encima de la ley nunca antes ha
habido dos estándares de justicia en el
país
Trump a tildó de asalto el registro del
FBI de su casa de Mara lago en agosto de
2022 y a la pregunta de por Qué guardaba
documentos clasificados en su residencia
respondió que todo eran objetos
personales como fotografías o camisetas
pero las pruebas no indican lo mismo
según el departamento de Justicia los
documentos contenían información sobre
defensa y programas nucleares entre
otros no obstante el multimillonario
siguió con su estrategia asegurar a
persecución política en su contra y
culpar a los demócratas de hacer lo
mismo o incluso peor en su discurso
señaló directamente a Joe biden Bill
Clinton o hillary Clinton y también
aprovechó para amenazar al actual
presidente y a toda su familia
nombraré a un fiscal real para que
persiga al presidente más corrupto en la
historia de los Estados Unidos de
América Joe biden y a toda la familia
criminal biden
ahora se espera que la defensa de Trump
se ampare en la presidencial Records
aunque los expertos aseguran que esta no
permite retener documentos clasificados
al concluir la presidencia
cambiamos de información porque el mundo
alcanzó el récord de 110 millones de
personas desplazadas y refugiadas en
2022 según el alto comisionado de
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados un
panorama propiciado por la crisis
climática la pobreza estructural o los
conflictos armados Es que de hecho los
recientes combates en Sudán la invasión
rusa de Ucrania o la crisis humanitaria
en Afganistán solo agravan la situación
un informe preocupante nunca el número
de refugiados y de desplazados en el
mundo había sido tan elevado la ONU ha
hecho las cuentas una cifra récord de
110 millones de personas se han visto
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares una
cifra que no deja de aumentar
recuerdan que hace unos años Incluso el
año pasado anunciamos por primera vez
que habíamos superado los 100 millones
de desplazados bien esa cifra ha
aumentado un 10%
es una verdadera acusación contra el
estado de nuestro mundo si se me permite
decirlo tener y anunciar eso la razón de
este fuerte aumento los conflictos en
particular el que afecta a Sudán los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército y los
paramilitares han disparado el número de
desplazados en las últimas semanas
la guerra en Ucrania también ha
contribuido a este aumento récord otra
lección de las Naciones Unidas tres
cuartos de estos refugiados huyen a
países de bajos ingresos esto contradice
la idea a menudo difundida sobre todo en
Europa de migrantes que abrumarían a las
naciones ricas
el alto comisionado para los refugiados
ha lanzado un mensaje a los dirigentes
políticos a menudo oímos la opinión
pública está harta no podemos aceptar a
nadie más gobernar también significa
convencer a la opinión pública de que
ciertas personas necesitan protección
internacional y de que hay que hacer
todo lo posible para conseguirlo
acnur también ha reconocido que no
dispone de los medios necesarios para
ayudar a esos millones de refugiados
precisamente el día que acnur revela
estas cifras 78 personas mueren en un
nuevo naufragio frente a las costas de
Grecia mientras intentaban llegar a
Europa según la guardia costera 106
personas han sido rescatadas con vida
pero se estima que cerca de 400 iban en
la embarcación recordemos que el
Mediterráneo es una concurrida ruta
migratoria y regular ante la falta de
alternativas legales para llegar a
Europa Pero también es la frontera más
mortífera del mundo desde 2014 cuando
empezó el conteo de la oim
27.000 personas han muerto en este mar
cambiamos de tema porque el ciclón
vipersoy que se encuentra actualmente en
el mar arábigo golpeará las costas de
India y Pakistán este jueves 15 de junio
y según las autoridades de estos dos
países el ejército así como equipos de
rescate han sido ya desplegados en la
provincia de sin en el sur de Pakistán
para ayudar a evacuar a la población de
las zonas consideradas de mayor riesgo
también se están llevando a cabo
operaciones de evacuación en el estado
indio de cucharadita el informe es de
malbenoman
[Música]
mientras el ciclón se acerca
peligrosamente a India y Pakistán las
autoridades de ambos países intentan
organizarse para evacuar a las decenas
de miles de personas que podrían correr
peligro
la fuerza Nacional de rescate ha
desplegado 18 equipos en los últimos dos
días una evacuación masiva fue llevada a
cabo por las partes interesadas entre
ellas de la fuerza Nacional de rescate y
las fuerzas estatales
que significa desastre en bengalí Está
avanzando por el mar arábigo y se espera
que toque tierra el jueves entre el sur
de Pakistán y el oeste de India en
Pakistán entre 22.000 y 23.000
habitantes de aldeas situadas junto al
mar han sido trasladados tierra adentro
y alojados en refugios temporales
estamos en malas condiciones no tenemos
suficiente comida ni medicinas para
nuestros hijos enfermos las autoridades
nos trajeron aquí en vehículos ahora la
situación no es buena las lluvias
torrenciales y Los Fuertes vientos
provocados por el ciclón que se aproxima
ya han causado la muerte de al menos 27
personas en el noroeste de Pakistán en
India en el estado de guajarat 45000
personas ya han sido desplazadas Aquí
también las lluvias y los vientos se han
cobrado tres vidas mientras que
alrededor de 1,6 millones de personas
corren Peligro en 2021 la misma región
fue azotada por el ciclón tautae que
causó más de 150 muertos los ciclones
son una amenaza habitual para las costas
del Norte del océano Índico pero los
científicos estiman que estos fenómenos
tienden a hacerse más violentos como
consecuencia del calentamiento global
vamos ahora a Italia porque La carroza
fúnebre con los restos mortales de
Silvio berlusconi llegó a la catedral de
Milán donde se desarrolla ya una
ceremonia fúnebre mientras el país se
mantiene en Duelo nacional
coronas de flores y pancartas de equipos
de fútbol adornaron la fachada del duomo
para honrar al fallecido Magnate líder
de derechas y cuatro veces Primer
Ministro de los italianos dos pantallas
gigantes permiten que la gente siga el
funeral desde la Plaza Central de la
ciudad el cuerpo será incinerado y sus
cenizas llevadas al mausoleo familiar en
los terrenos de su Villa en arcore
actualizamos ahora las noticias de la
guerra en Ucrania porque las autoridades
de kiev señalaron que un ataque ruso con
misiles mató a tres personas y causó una
decena de heridos en el puerto de Odessa
en el sur del país y hoy mismo tres
personas más murieron en la región de
idoniesk mientras por otro lado
Moscú acusa a kiev de atacar una zona
Residencial en Nova kahozca la ciudad
bajó control ruso recordemos en las
inmediaciones de la presa que colapsó la
semana pasada y en otras noticias de la
guerra el presidente de belarus
Alexander lukashenko aseguró que comenzó
a recibir armas nucleares rusas
el enemigo atacó la región de odesa con
misiles de Calibre disparados desde el
mar Negro la fuerte ola de explosiones
dañó varios edificios un negocio en el
centro Una institución educativa y
tiendas la batalla aérea tuvo lugar en
el centro de la ciudad de Odessa
y el gobierno de Francia acusó a Rusia
de llevar a cabo una campaña de
desinformación a gran escala el
Ministerio de exteriores francés afirmó
que las noticias falsas en contra de
Ucrania se han hecho pasar por
publicaciones de medios de comunicación
franceses
en un primer vistazo esta página se
parece inconfundiblemente a la del
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores Francés
pero si se ve más de cerca se descubre
que es falsa casi una réplica que forma
parte de una campaña de desinformación
de Rusia
las autoridades francesas han
descubierto una importante campaña de
desinformación rusa con noticias falsas
hostiles a Ucrania hechas para que
parecieran publicadas por destacados
medios de comunicación franceses
le monta afirma que los agentes que
crearon y difundieron esta falsa página
web también están detrás de numerosas
imitaciones de periódicos franceses como
le parecían y Ben minute así como de
importantes medios alemanes como de
también han circulado imitaciones
similares en Italia y el Reino Unido en
medio de la creciente preocupación por
las campañas de desinformación rusas en
los países occidentales el modus
operandi es el mismo un artículo falso
por Moscú criticando al presidente
ucraniano voló de mirza lensky por
ejemplo o denunciando las sanciones
contra Rusia además de impulsar el
discurso del crimen las campañas parecen
tener el objetivo secundario de hacer
creer que existe un apoyo Popular a
Rusia dentro de la Unión Europea la
ministra francesa de asuntos exteriores
demasiado las campañas diciendo que
Moscú intenta socavar las instituciones
democráticas e influir en la opinión
pública internacional sobre su invasión
de Ucrania vamos ahora a Japón donde un
soldado de 18 años mató a tiros a dos de
sus instructores e hirió a un tercero el
crimen fue atendido por el personal de
la fuerza de autodefensa terrestre de
Japón y la policía los tres baleados
fueron llevados al hospital donde solo
uno sobrevivió fue el primer tiroteo
fatal de este tipo en un campo de tiro
de la fuerza desde 1984 el agresor
acababa de incorporarse al servicio en
abril
en otras noticias en El Salvador el
congreso aprobó la reducción del número
de municipios que pasará de 262 a 44 a
partir de mayo de 2024 según el
presidente del Congreso la reducción del
número de municipios supone un ahorro de
250 millones de dólares anuales mientras
la oposición señala que es una táctica
del gobierno de bukele para mantener el
control territorial además el pasado 7
de junio recordemos el congreso aprobó
reducir de 84 a 60 los escaños del
legislativo
y falleció a los 89 años cormac mccarthy
el novelista ganador del premio
pulitcher que es en una densa prosa
llevó a los lectores del sur de Los
apalanques al desierto del suroeste
novelas como la carretera meridiano de
sangre y todos los hermosos caballos la
editorial dependen a Random House
anunció que el autor estadounidense se
murió por causas naturales en su casa de
Santa Fe en Nuevo México millones de
lectores de todo el mundo abrazaron sus
personajes sus temas míticos y las
verdades
íntimas de sus historias que
permanecerán en sus obras
y el universo de Harry Potter abrirá su
segundo parque temático con la promesa
de seguir atrayendo a los fans de la
saga más famosa del mundo y es que los
seguidores de esta franquicia
cinematográfica y literaria que cumple
22 años este año pronto podrán a tomar
sus varitas mágicas ponerse sus túnicas
y sumergirse en el mundo mágico en este
nuevo estudio que se inaugurará el
próximo viernes en Tokio la capital
japonesa las entradas para adultos
cuestan lo equivalente a 45 Dólares pero
no se ha abierto el parque y ya se
agotaron las reservas hasta agosto ya
existe una instalación similar en
Londres desde 2012 pero las nuevas
instalaciones ampliarán la experiencia
hasta aquí las noticias gracias por su
atención
[Música]